Speaker 1: All right. Let's start in a way we
haven't started for a while, which is by talking
about the coronavirus pandemic. You know, I
got a few emails from people saying, David,
if you want to be fair, you've got to call out
Joe Biden for something that he recently said.
Joe Biden recently said the pandemic is over.
That's not true. And if you're going to be fair,
you can't let that slide while I call out
anybody who says things that aren't true.
And Joe Biden did on 60 Minutes say the
pandemic is over and the pandemic is not over.
And I will make that case in a moment, but maybe
maybe not in the way you would assume I would make
it. So let's first listen to what Joe Biden said.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, first Detroit Auto Show
in three years. Yeah. Is the pandemic over? The
pandemic is over. We still have a problem with
COVID. We're still doing a lot of work on it.
It's but the pandemic is over. If you notice,
no one's wearing masks. Everybody seems to be in
pretty good shape. And so I think it's changing.
And I think this is a perfect example of it.
Speaker 1: This is pretty silly. It really
is. Now, there's two interpretations here. When
Joe Biden says, listen, the pandemic is over,
as evidenced by the auto show is back. There is
no masks and everyone here seems to be doing okay.
You know, forget about the millions that that have
died for a second. But this really isn't true.
Now, this isn't about me. I am not saying I need
to hold on to every guideline we ever had. No,
I mean, I'm not wearing masks. I'm out in the
world. I'm doing things. This is not a question of
of me. My behavior is basically back to normal.
But it's not true that the pandemic is over.
When you look at the sort of numbers that we
have right now in the United States, you know,
an average of somewhere between 60 and 90,000
new cases a day. When we had 100 cases a day at
the start of the pandemic, it was a disaster. We
now have 60 to 90000 that we know of and probably
two or three times more from people doing
home tests are not getting tested at all.
When you look at the death numbers,
we still have somewhere between,
you know, three and 500 people dying every single
day from COVID. So here are the things Joe Biden
could have said that would have been true. We've
gotten accustomed to the current level of death
from COVID, and we consider it normal and
acceptable and a fair exchange to going back to
our normal lives. Generally speaking, that would
have been an accurate statement from Joe Biden
or we don't think we really can reduce the
number of deaths from where they are right now.
So we're not even really going to try. Okay.
I mean, that that would have been an accurate
statement. I think it is true to say that
politically the pandemic rhetoric has ended,
but there's no real way mathematically to make the
case that the pandemic is over. And to be clear,
I am not coming at this from I'm trying to get
everybody back in their homes and wearing masks
and no large gatherings or anything. I'm
not advocating for any of that. I'm part of
the group that has said, you know, it seems
like it's going to be like this at least
for a few more years. And at a certain point,
it's understandable that for the most part,
most people have gone completely back to normal.
Am I going to large sporting events right now? No,
I'm not. But I was already kind of starting not to
before the pandemic, just because the crowds are
annoying and I hate sitting in traffic and all
of that stuff. But to say the pandemic is over,
you can't really back it up with any statistical
data. And so what we have done and it's okay to
accept this, it is I mean, a similar thing
happened after the flu pandemic of 1918.
The pandemic ends culturally and socially in a way
before there is any medical end to the pandemic.
And because COVID is a little different and we
see. Without getting now into the medical part of
it, between variants and all these other things.
It's likely going to be around for a while, if
not longer than a while. The medical end may not
come for a period of time. It may not ever come,
in a sense, but the political and the social and
the cultural and we expect it would happen sooner
now. What will things look like in January? Who
knows? But that would be a more fair assessment
as of right now. So Joe Biden is just wrong. I
still agree with student loan debt forgiveness.
I still think the Inflation Reduction Act is
good. I still think Joe Biden has done a lot
more good things than many recent presidents. But
on this particular thing, he simply is incorrect.